Film Courage: How does someone decide where to start
their story? Mark W. Travis, Director/Author/Writer/Instructor: Wow ...where to
start the story? Now I'm assuming we have
this little three or four or five
minutes story right a little I'm gonna
stay with us you mean where to start
that story? Film Courage: Well if they're going to tell
people their life what if they don't
want to say well at all hey you know I
was raised in such-and-such a town what
if they want to start it from the time
that they left college okay because they
feel like that's when their real self
began? Mark: Okay we need we need to talk
about two things then now I understand
more we need two under the sequencing. Okay
sequencing of information which I can
talk about which has to do with the
events in a story and do you really want
to start with the beginning of the story
do you want to start with something in
the middle and other words plane with
the sequence the chronology of events as
you tell the story so that's one thing
the the other thing we can talk about
when you say tell the story of my life
there's another topic and which I'm
willing to forget what we're shooting
now but another topic which is about how
an autobiographical story is put
together because it's put together
differently than a screenplay it's put
together differently than novels put
together differently than fiction and
how we the process I use to explore what
the story is really about through the
writing and don't make a determination
at the beginning so those are two times
that makes sense so sequencing and then
sequencing and then structuring the
autobiographical story which are two
different
the structure in is which story comes
first in the sequence of stories and
then there's the sequencing within a
story so is that something you would
determine if someone presents you I'm
sorry I'm presents me what so when you
work with someone how do they decide
where to begin
okay let's talk about out of where to
begin with just one little story if
someone is told a story and done that
I'm just gonna go back to your...Film Courage: You know
can we stop? My life is very dull and  I'm not
really interested in talking about me?
Sorry, why don't we do a
hypothetical version of Karen who's much
more exciting a hypothetical. Mark: That's
fiction! That's fiction! Okay something... Film Courage:
Another Karen who's had an amazing, wild,
incredible life. Mark: Okay I'm going to tell
you a quick story right now one of my
stories
and we'll use that we'll use that as an
example okay and I'll tell you just just
give you an overview of the story this
is when I was nine years old about to
become 10 years old and so I was about
to have my 10th birthday I have an older
brother and older sister and I have
younger siblings too but my parents
always made the tenth birthday a special
birthday special gift
extraordinary so as I'm approaching as I
was approaching my tenth birthday I was
very excited about what's my gift gonna
be I had seen when my older brother
Peter got it was great at least he
thought it was great but it was great
and it was very expensive and I saw what
my sister got she thought it was great
they were very happy and so I wanted
something that was equally as great or
actually better I thought mine should be
better and so I was waiting for that
moment and then it comes the morning and
my birthday and I'm waking up I can
barely sleep i'm waking up i can't wait
until the we get to the the time of the
day when i'm gonna open the presents and
all of that and my father was saying
happy birthday and i'm thinking oh it's
a special gift i think it might be it
could be a bike I'm hoping it's gonna be
a bike
or I'm how I was hoping that it could be
maybe something like skates ice skating
because I was into ice skating and I
also wanted maybe some new skis
something like that bicycle skate skis
that would have been great
and I was just sitting there wondering
what its gonna be and then the time came
when we're opening the gifts and the
whole family is around my older
brother's sister and the younger ones
are there and when they were there and
when I opened the gift I don't even know
if you'll know what this is when I tell
you when I opened the gift what was
inside was a wooden press to keep a
tennis racket from warping now I played
tennis I knew what this was I had a
tennis racket in fact a new tennis
racket might have been nice but why did
I need a new press because they were
wooden tennis racquets back then and I
was just devastated and disappointed and
my father seemed very pleased and my
mother seemed very pleased but my
brother seemed smug Peter right Peter
yeah and faith seemed not terribly
interested so I didn't get what I wanted
why do you think they gave you that
because they I don't know is it what it
represented to you that you weren't what
my yeah I think what that story is
really about Karen is as the third child
in a family of six children
I really felt less than most of the
other children except maybe my youngest
sister but anyway the last the sixth one
and at that time at 10 years old I think
what I really wanted to feel I wanted to
feel is that I was as special if not
more special than my older brother and
sister and this 10th birthday gift would
do it and only once would you get to do
this and I know what they got and I know
and then I saw what I got and it just
didn't do it so my expectation is that
after they get the gift I my self-esteem
would be super high I would feel proud
of myself I would feel important but I
didn't okay
now getting back to sequencing a story
right the question is with that story
where do you start now this story and
you know this from filmmaking to a story
could start at the moment of opening the
gift say what would happen I could this
world will do with students a lot and
what would happen if you start with the
opening of the gift well then I said
yeah but no but you don't reveal what
the gift is you you start at the moment
of the opening of the get the moment
when the adrenaline is so high and the
anticipation is so huge and you start
then and then you go back to the big to
the beginning and start that way well it
happens if you tell the story out of
order the important thing is that by the
time the story is told completely
the audience has all the information
that you're going to give them that's it
but it doesn't mean they need it in
chronological order in fact it could
start after the opening after as I'm
walking back to my room I could start
with the story talking about me walking
back to my room with my gifts devastated
destroyed feeling despondent I feel like
I want to cry it could start there and
now if you think about it if you start
there the audience is going what
happened what happened to you that it
was so awful and you're carrying
birthday gifts and you want to cry the
audience has no frame of reference to
make sense out of that which is great
because it makes the audience curious
then they can go back to the excitement
about what I'm going to get now the
audience knows the end and they're
trying to figure then not try to figure
out where it's going to go but they're
trying to feel how did it get from this
to that
I couldn't even throw in the middle of
it how much I love tennis threw out in
the middle of the story so that the
tennis the the press for the tennis
racket the audience think well that's
great but they realize it's not very cuz
it's not greater than what Peter and
faith got and where do I get that
information in so it's it's it's not so
that's ass that's the sequencing where
are you going to start where do you want
to finish that's the sequencing of a
story now this is actually a lot of the
storytelling techniques that we teach in
write your life with autobiographical
stories come from film film editing now
you've seen films that start in the
middle you've seen events that start
there you've seen flashbacks you go what
is that and all of that process
you